oh hi I didn't see you there sorry about
the Burt Reynolds player elbows up to
embarrass we're going to show you an
exercise that is called Cathedral and it
is very useful for handstand practice or
any type of inversion practice and
engaging the musculature that will be
very important for anything more
advanced there are different ways to
practice handstands and of course one of
the limiting factors for a lot of people
is the risks the risks will get really
grumpy the forms or get a really lit up
the elbows and get really lit up so how
do you practice more how do you add
volume without destroying these joints
especially as a novice there are few
ways you can go about doing it some
people will do they'll do posts like
this will actually post on the forearms
other people will use something called a
feet up or a shoulder stand that
basically looks like a padded toilet
seat and they stick their head through
so that they can place the weight on
their shoulders and then perform
exercises but what if you don't have any
of this equipment well it turns out you
can use a partner for very simple
exercise relatively simple and there's a
progression so kiplyn a good friend here
at qmk i plin
on instagram and everywhere else is
going to demonstrate what this looks
like and in effect I'm just supporting
her in shoulder stand I'll give some
commentary as we go through all right so
like so now as I place my hands I'm
basically taking the palms and putting
them to the point where they feel like
they're going to slip but just before my
hands are very widely open like so and
you elicit that Kipling's give me a
little bit of weight so that I can make
sure they're not going to totally slip I
do have a little bit of chalk on my
hands too okay from here she's putting
her hands on my thighs stepping up my
arms are straight I'm pushing a bit with
the fingertips and then she's going to
do a progression
straddle
and then you can do any number of
different things okay so that would be
from a pipe position she did a tuck that
would be a little bit easier and then
you can also do straddle work so many
different ways to work in this position
to get more mileage without totally
destroying your joints if you're putting
all of your weight and then you can do
things like this which I can't do
but sometimes Lexy fliers can get it
done and the way this translates that
position that we just did is you want to
do bird to shoulder stand to helicopter
so the way that translates as a base
you're developing skill to do stuff like
this okay so this is the beginners
version and then if we wanted to which
is a free-standing version looks like
that and then you can do all sorts of
cool things like we come up and rotate
helicopter that we can even go through
it second time like so tada huh there
you have it if you enjoyed that video
let's talk about a list Arnold
Schwarzenegger Jamie Foxx undisputed
king of big wave surfing Laird Hamilton
the list goes on and on what do they
have in common they're sharing their
secrets their morning routines favorite
books everything with me on my podcast
the Tim Ferriss show 70 million plus
downloads iTunes best of 2015
check it out you will not be
disappointed